[Music]
hey everyone how's it going so we've all
heard the term dress to impress which
basically means you dressing up a
certain way to impress a certain group
of individuals sometimes to get respect
sometimes to get attention and sometimes
to get admiration and I remember when I
was going into the tech industry and
figuring out what do I wear to
interviews what do I wear to work it was
kind of top of my for me because I
wanted to make sure that as soon as I go
into a job that I was going to feel and
be treated like a software engineer now
if you think about how software
engineers dress the media and other
places often depict software engineers
is wearing a tech t-shirt
sometimes a text jacket or a sweatshirt
jeans and sneakers thinking about this
really generic outfit is outfit that
most software engineers wear even the
ones that are top of the field when I
graduated college I was like I have to
wear this outfit in order to get some
sort of street cred cuz honestly I
wanted to be seen it's like one of the
group I wanted to be like hey like I am
one of you trust me look at what I'm
wearing
I guess but you know four years out of
college and four years is working as a
software engineer I realized that was I
was kind of dumb because you know in
that time between me graduating college
now I've gone through a lot of change
thought about a lot of things thought
about me myself and I basically as
someone who works in the tech industry
and I've come to a couple realizations
one of these things is that fashion is a
great way to express your individuality
which I know it's like basics but I
didn't internalize this until recently
one way that I like to think about
fashion is that fashion is a way to give
energy to yourself or to others and I
like fashion now because it's a great
way to give energy to myself like for
instance if I'm tired because maybe I
didn't get enough sleep then wearing
something that I like wearing gives me
so much energy to get me through the day
the other thing that I realized about
this whole like generic outfit of tech
people is that I think it's actually
pretty related to the whole gender gap
problem the gender gap being that
there's a lot more men in software
engineering
non men so in that way if you think
about it of course like the whole
software engineer look is going to favor
kind of men's clothing in fashion which
by the way I really like men's fashion
men's fashion is so cool and I'm into it
but you know I don't know I feel like we
could do better than like a tech t-shirt
in jeans
so obviously the gender gap is a huge
role to play in what people wear to
their software engineering jobs but also
internally like that whole street cred
thing of oh maybe I should be wearing
this to get street cred was honestly
because I was judging people who weren't
wearing that and yeah that's pretty bad
like I was judging people for wearing a
certain thing and assessing their
credibility and software engineering
based on that which spoilers like don't
do that that's not very nice and that
whole street cred thing is like pretty
dumb but granted I'm sure there are
people in the tech industry who do judge
based on that so yeah so after I thought
about all these things that were at play
that influenced how I think about what
to wear to a tech job I thought about
what would I wear to my text job if
these things weren't in play and to me I
realized that it's wearing things that
are comfortable that give me energy and
give me a lot of confidence so because
I've been on this kind of mini journey
if you will thinking about the
relationship between fashion and my work
I wanted to share with y'all what I wear
to work in a week so there are five
outfits in total and I have been wearing
all of these on a heavy rotation
especially for kind of warmer weather I
did try to mix in a little bit of like
cooler weather stuff so hopefully
that'll be some sort of fall-like trend
thing that's a thing that people do
right like fall lookbooks I don't know
call it whatever you would like I wanted
to make this video because I wanted to
empower you to wear something that feels
more you and it's not necessarily feel
like you have to wear a certain thing
because of certain societal things but
don't go to work naked or wearing
something inappropriate it's a
professional setting after all but I
think there is still a lot of room to
express yourself let me get that
out there before we start I wanted to
note that I live and work in the Bay
Area and that does have a huge role to
play in what I wear to work because
there's a lot of cultural things and
also just weather things that influence
like what I can and cannot wear to work
and lastly I work at a tech startup kind
of in the arts and creative space and so
I think that also has a big part to play
in what I wear to work as well so this
first outfit is definitely for days that
are a little bit on the warmer side I'm
wearing a one-piece black dress from
Uniqlo it has like a built in bra in it
so it's super comfortable to wear and
around my waist I'm wearing my Levi's
jean jacket which I bought on Amazon and
I talked about it in a favorites video a
couple months back I still love it I
love that it kind of just divides my top
half and my bottom half a little bit
because it's just a super simple black
dress I'm wearing my onizuka Tigers
white sneakers that I bought from a long
time ago I always have a pair of white
sneakers in my closet because I feel
like it goes with everything and it ties
together an outfit super well I really
like curling my hair for this outfit
because I feel like it just brings some
more personality into it and I love that
if it gets a little bit Trilly I can
actually just take off my jacket and put
it on my shoulders and it looks just as
good
so this next outfit features a piece in
my wardrobe that I absolutely love it's
one of my favorite things which is this
green army jacket I got this at a
vintage store a long time ago and it is
so soft and nice and big and I love it's
so comfortable the patches on the side
and the patch on the chest really bring
it kind of some personality apparently
there they have real meaning but I love
wearing this jacket I love the color I
love the texture I love everything about
it underneath I'm just wearing a very
simple white striped t-shirt I have so
many striped t-shirts and striped shirts
in my wardrobe and this is just one of
them because I think they are a staple
and I'm wearing ripped skinny jeans from
Uniqlo I tend to always gravitate
towards wearing black jeans and these
ones are super comfortable I'm wearing
my vans slip-ons these are also really
comfortable and I think very fashionable
they're easy to wear and I can walk in
them for so long and I really really
like this outfit a lot so this next
outfit is definitely for cooler weather
and on come for your days it features
this nasty jacket that I bought a couple
of weeks ago that I really really like I
got it from H&M and I just found it on
the rack it has this big NASA logo on
the back and a NASA logo on the front
and it's kind of oversized and so it's
very roomy and it's so comfortable I'm
wearing the same black jeans that are
ripped to give it a little bit more
personality and then my adidas runner
shoes that are also really comfortable
and really sleek one of my favorite
parts about this jacket is the hood I
really like big hoods that I can just
kind of like snuggle and hide into and
this one is particularly good so yeah
it's it's a quality jacket and it's
still fuzzy and I really like it
so this next outfit I feel like is
really fun and actually kind of feminine
it features these green white pants yes
that is correct you heard pants there
it's not a skirt and it also has pockets
they're super comfortable very roomy I
could wear these all day because
actually I really don't like wearing
jeans and I love the wide pant trend
that's going on right now it's this
really pretty colored green you'll see
that I gravitate towards these kind of
earthy er tones a lot and it's really
fun and comfortable to wear and I feel
like it's pretty flattering on top I'm
wearing a very simple black Uniqlo shirt
very soft I really like uni clothes
stuff because it's very soft and very
easy to wear and again I'm wearing my
Onizuka Tigers white sneakers for this
look I really like this all because it's
really fun and I think the pants are
what makes it super fun and I feel
feminine in it I feel fun in it it's
super loose it's very comfortable and I
am a fan of these wide leg pants and I
want more so this last look I call it
kind of the wannabe skater boy look
because it features a couple of Vannes
items on top I'm wearing a shirt that I
bought from vans that's kind of cropped
it's just a shorter crop it has this
really cute embroider in the front that
says vans and on the back it says
off-the-wall
I really like the right embroidery and
also the detail of the neckline is also
really cool too I feel like it's a
pretty fun shirt and it kind of goes
with a bunch of stuff on the bottom I'm
wearing these high-waisted straight
jeans from every lane every lane is a
sustainable clothing company based in
San Francisco and this was one of my
first items from them I really like
these pants because I'm actually used to
wearing more skinny jeans but because of
the relaxed fit of this these are way
way more comfortable and also kind of
have that mom Jean vibe which I'm really
really into right now and then for my
shoes I'm wearing my band slip-ons again
because this is my skater look and I
gotta be wearing some skater shoes you
know
cool so I hope you liked this video and
if you did please give it a thumbs up
and leave and comment down below about
what you thought and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel and turn the
notification bell on to get notified for
my new videos I actually wanted to give
a shout out to this Instagram profile
that I found called my flair ladies
there are two women who work in tech who
post their ootds outfits of the day
every single day on their Instagram page
and they are so fashionable and I really
really like it so definitely go check
them out and I wanted to say thank you
to the sponsor of this video expressvpn
which is a VPN service so I've been
thinking a lot more about privacy lately
especially with the big Facebook hack
but also thinking about how the internet
and other companies track my data and
use that to sell me stuff or to use it
maliciously and honestly one of the best
solutions for this is to use a VPN
service basically without a VPN your
information can be tracked and collected
by companies and by hackers and buy or
sell your provider but when you do use a
VPN your public IP address is masked and
so they can't identify who you are
Express VPN is awesome for that because
they have locations in 94 countries so
you can choose wherever you want to
spoof your location from they also have
24/7 customer support whenever you need
it which I always love when companies do
24/7 customer support they also have
apps for every device so whether you're
using iOS or Android or Windows or Mac
or Linux or whatever else then they
likely have an app for you and they give
you internet access without any
restriction so you can stream stuff you
can download stuff to do whatever so it
is less than $7 a month with a 30-day
money-back guarantee so be sure to take
back your internet privacy today and
find out how you can get three months
for you by going to expressvpn comm
slash my echo or by clicking the link in
the description box below let's eat XP
or ESS VPN comm slash may you go at four
three months free with the 1-year
package this is your cue to visit
expressvpn comm slash where you go to
learn more and take back your internet
privacy today alright folks that is it
for today and I'll see you next time bye
[Music]